but first America in shutdown day 17 now
beyond the numbers that flash on the
screen counting those infected and
killed by kovat 19 and they're always
horrific we often forget through the
sadness and the fear that this is also
causing American our American family a
lot of pain we have to ask what is this
virus doing to us as a people as we deal
with the victims and trying to prevent
more deaths well apparently it's turning
us into a nation of snitches if you've
observed recurring violations of the
safer at home order please continue to
let us know at coronavirus LA city org
slash business violation you know the
old expression about snitches well in
this case snitches get rewards we want
to thank you for turning folks in and
making sure we are all safe I have a
question mayor Garcetti of Los Angeles
who keeps us safe from you it's become
abundantly clear that in the midst of
this unprecedented health crisis that
there are bad actors everywhere trying
to use this to their advantage Shawn and
I were just talking about some of them
from washed up celebrities lip syncing
their greatest hits on YouTube to
politicians using fear to cram down
policies that would be inconceivable to
us under normal circumstances now while
we as a nation continue doing our part
to keep ourselves and each other safe
during these very difficult days we
cannot stand idly by as people in either
party take advantage of this very
complicated and dire situation as a
society beyond just this immediate
situation we should start looking
forward to understand how this
experience is going to change us or how
it should change us because this is
going to be transformative when do we
get back to
I don't think we get back to normal wait
wait wait a second wait it's like we
don't get back to normal now I thought
the whole point of locking ourselves our
homes was to save lives of course and
then go back to our old normal lives now
the Democrats think they have President
Trump in a no-win situation that's
obvious from the way they're acting so
they're not even worried at this point
about hiding their agenda are you taking
into consideration green jobs green
infrastructure yes and if we're gonna do
infrastructure if we made it big we
needed old and we need a futuristic
which means green there's traditional
infrastructure roads bridges highways we
need that but we also need new green
infrastructure for the future phase for
kovin meet Solyndra maybe we can call it
Cove Indra Green absolutely absurd and
this should be exposed and resisted at
all costs by the GOP come on now if
they're not going green though they're
going for the guns because the same
liberal governors who classified
abortion clinics as essential businesses
rushed in to close gun stores as
non-essential and gun owners well they
weren't happy we weren't willing to just
sit by and watch people's rights be
violated the right to keep and bear arms
necessarily includes the right to
acquire them how can you keep how can
you bear something you can't get your
hands on
now here's boxes freakout headline from
earlier today flatten the curve and your
second Amendment rights check that out
well mayor's are also using the virus to
empty their jails some violent offenders
have already gone on to commit other
crimes and since we're talking about
lawbreakers they have advocates in the
White House briefing room two over five
million
in this country do pay taxes through
their ID numbers yet they will not
receive any money in their stimulus
package how do you suppose they survive
during the covert 19 well you know
you're seeing undocumented meaning they
came in illegally and a lot of people
would say we have a lot of citizens
right now that won't be working so what
are you gonna do it's a tough thing I'm
not gonna give you a hard and fast
answer because I just want to tell you
it's something I think about and it's
something we're working on now well of
course everyone feels bad for everyone
in this situation here and we love
immigrants but the operative word in
President Trump now is this he said it
so many times is legal immigrants and
right now with everything we're facing
it's gotta be Americans first but of all
the scams perpetrated through the kovat
nightmare the effort to change voting we
told you like two weeks ago this was
going to happen is perhaps the worst
anything to create more opportunities
for ballot harvesting or even voter
fraud we need one point six billion
dollars added to the next covert
response bill to ensure that vote by
mail in-person early voting and Election
Day voting can happen it will probably
be moving to vote by mail it may mean
that you have a circumstance where you
have Drive in voting literally Lia pull
up and you get booked I don't even know
what biden was saying there poll kind of
trails off at the end of those sentences
it doesn't mean but it's not only the
democrats playing games here former
trump administration FDA Commissioner
well he's actually seeing his own demand
peak Scott Gottlieb he's on television
several times a day and has the ear of
the White House he's written a kind of
roadmap to recovery plan that discusses
the need to do a bunch of things to get
back to normal
including in part tracking citizens
movement during this crisis now some of
this is already happening sources told
the Wall Street Journal that the federal
state and local governments have already
started coal
acting and studying geolocation data now
it turns out that big tech is helping
Big Brother track York ovid compliance
now we expect this kind of stuff from
China and Russia maybe even Korea but
here now when I was a student in the
Soviet Union they watched our every move
there were informants in our hotel and
the coffee stand up little coffee shops
and they all received special government
privileges for ratting out you know
tourists into the Soviet Union or even
their fellow citizens my goodness we
can't have that here now in the coming
days and the coming weeks we're going to
be doing some tracking of our own of the
models funded by billionaires that keep
Americans out of work
you know projections that are based in
faulty assumptions and in some cases
even incomplete data Congress may be out
of session while you're out of work but
not us hundreds of thousands of
Americans die every year from horrific
things viruses pneumonia obviously old
age cancer diabetes are there terrible
illnesses they also die from despair
drug overdoses opioids suicide and
loneliness every life is precious and we
have to ensure that winning the war
against kovat 19 doesn't kill the
patient which is America and those are
my thoughts at the end of this shutdown
day 17